Now you can see how we apply these rules of inferences on sentences in
a knowledge base or philosophical agent to prove all kinds of sentences. See,
imagine that an AI agent begins with the knowledge that if an animal has
feathers, it implies that the animal is a bird. Now it comes across Harry,
who does have feathers. By Modus Ponens,
therefore the AI agent can conclude that Harry is a bird.
This completes the proof for our original goal of proving that Harry is a bird.
Now let us suppose that a goal is to prove that Buzz does not have feathers.
Once again, imagine an AI agent which begins with the knowledge that if
an animal has feathers, it implies that the animal has, is a bird.
The agent comes across a animal, which is not a bird. Then by Modus Tollens
it can infer that buzz must not have feathers. This completes the proof for
of a original goal of proving that buzz does not have feathers. Okay. So
now, we have looked at two ways of proving the truth value of various sentences.
The first way was just through truth tables. I could have sentences and
logic. Then I could write another sentence. And ask myself, what,
what is the truth value of this sentence? I could construct a truth table for
that sentence, composed of the truth values of all the predicates,
with some of which might be coming from earlier sentences. The second way in
which we have seen how we can prove the truth values of sentences and
logic is by applying these rules of inferences like modus ponens and
modus tollens. This is very powerful, and in fact the power of this logic has
been known since before the birth of AI. As computer scientists however,
we'll analyze this power in a slightly different way. Yes, we can use method of
truth tables to construct a truth table for any arbitrary sentence. However,
the sentence was complicated. Then the truth table very soon will become very
complex. Computationally, that is infeasible for very long,
large sentences. Similarly, yes we can apply simply modus ponens and
modus tollens to find the truth value of many sentences. But if the knowledge
base consisted of a very large number of sentences, instead of just one or
two sentences, then the kinds of inferences, number of inferences I
can draw from those sentences simply by applying modus ponens and modus tollens,
will be very large. Or if I had to find the truth value of a single sentence,
then the different pathways I could take in order to get to the truth value of
those sentences can make for long, large problem space. So while these
methods of proving the truth with your sentences and logic have been around for
a long time. These methods are not computationally feasible. At least not for
complex tasks. At least not for agents that have only limited computational
resources and from who we want near realtime performance